bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après midi
en direct sur notre antenne
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
répartition des contentieux et à
l'allègement de certaines procédures
juridictionnelles
ce texte concerne des aspects très
différents de l'activité judiciaire
comme par exemple la réforme des
juridictions de proximité la réforme en
matière de divorce ou encore le recours
à une médiation familiale
l'objectif est de rendre la justice plus
simple et plus accessible
les sénateurs qui ont examiné ce texte
en commission ont cependant regretté que
l'examen de ce projet de loi
interviennent dans un contexte
budgétaire restreint tout de suite donc
la direction l'hémicycle du sénat
poursuivre la discussion générale très
bonne séance à tous
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la répartition des contentieux
et à l'allègement de certaines
procédures juridictionnelles sous
procédure accélérée dans la discussion
générale la parole est un monsieur
michel mercier garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice et des libertés
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mais
sur les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le projet de loi
qui vous est soumis s'inscrit pleinement
dans un mouvement initié en 2009 et
destiné à mettre en oeuvre les
propositions de la commission sur la
répartition des contentieux présidée par
le recteur serge guinchard qui avait
rendu ses excellentes conclut
conclusions en juin 2008
outre la loi du 22 décembre 2010 de la
loi du 28 mars 2011 de modernisation des
professions judiciaires et juridiques
réglementées qui ont mise en oeuvre
nombre de ses préconisations
d'autres mesures significatives ont été
adoptées dans des textes différents
je veux rappeler que notamment dans la
loi du 12 mai 2009 il est créé un pôle
famille au sein des tribunaux de grande
instance que avec la loi du 1er juillet
2010 et réformer le traitement du
surendettement
c'est donc à la lumière de l'ensemble de
ces importantes réformes qui redessine
des progressions judiciaire que le
projet dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
doit être examiné ce projet poursuit
deux objectifs principaux
tout d'abord amelia améliorer la
répartition des contentieux en procédant
une clarification de l'organisation
judiciaire et simplifié enfin les
procédures en procédant à un allègement
des règles pour un traitement plus
efficace est des litiges
tout d'abord l'effort de clarification
et de simplification de la répartition
des contentieux et aux choeurs et du
texte cette clarification des
compétences s'imposait comme une
nécessité
après la réforme de la carte judiciaire
entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier dernier
avec une carte judiciaire plus cohérente
et mieux structuré et qui constituait
une première étape indispensable
elle devait s accompagner d'une
répartition plus clair et plus
rationalisée et des compétences et elle
est bien l'objet de ce texte qui offre
une plus grande visibilité et pour les
juridictions de première instance
entre le rôle du tribunal d'instance et
est celui et du tribunal de grande
instance
cette plus grande visibilité supposait
par ailleurs la suppression de la
juridiction proximité créée par la loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la justice d'une offre décembre 2002 en
effet la commission guinchard a souligné
la confusion et la complexité introduite
pour les justiciables et les praticiens
par l'existence de ce troisième ordres
de juridiction pour autant est la
lumière d'expériences la porte de 672
juge de proximité dans la vie de nos
tribunaux est indéniable c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a choisi
de les maths de les maintenir et de les
intégrer au sein des tribunaux de grande
instance
ce repositionnement contribuera à
améliorer le dialogue les échanges entre
les juges professionnels et les juges de
proximité
quelles seront les nouvelles missions
des juges de proximité ils pourront
participer aux audiences collégiales des
tribunaux d'instance non plus seulement
matière pénale mais aussi aux civils ce
qui d'ailleurs leur permettra dans ce
domaine aussi de procéder à des mesures
d'instruction quelques transport sur les
lieux où audition des parties et des
témoins ils pourront en outre se voir
confier la procédure non contradictoire
d'injonction de payer
celle-ci relevant des genres désormais
du tribunal de grande instance
au delà du seuil de dix mille euros les
juges de proximité conservons enfin
leurs compétences s'agissant des
contraventions des quatre premières
classes
notre commission des lois sous
l'impulsion de l'autre à porter dont je
salue le travail est de grande qualité a
approuvé des dispositions du texte sur
ce point je sais que s'interroge encore
sur certaines de leurs conséquences
pour ma part je suis très attaché à la
cohérence de la réforme
ben nous en débattrons naturellement le
moment venu
par ailleurs le texte poursuit aussi un
effort de spécialisation pour les
contentieux les plus complexes et
requérant un haut degré de technicité
afin d'améliorer l'efficacité des
enquêtes et instructions de réduire les
délais de jugement
le projet institue dans plusieurs pôles
spécialisés en matière pénale
je me réjouis du consensus autour ces
dispositions tant elle représente une
avancée d'importance dans les
contentieux sensible et qui sont en
cause ainsi un pôle national compétent
pour les crimes contre l'humanité des
crimes de guerre verra le jour au sein
de la juridiction parisienne l
initiative de la commission des lois
ce dont je me réjouis il aura aussi
compétence pour les crimes de torture
disait par la convention de new york du
10 décembre 1984 par cette
spécialisation des magistrats et des
enquêteurs nous améliorerons de
traitement des procédures dans ce
domaine
en outre à la suite de l'avant demande
du gouvernement le texte est issu de la
commission des lois prévoient des
capacités dans qu'être renforcée pour la
recherche des auteurs de crimes contre
l'humanité de crimes de guerre
l'ensemble de ces mesures souhaitées par
le gouvernement
derek lam et aussi par de nombreuses ong
sont ainsi un signal fort de la volonté
de la france de lutter contre les crimes
les plus graves et de disposer ainsi des
outils les plus efficaces pour assurer
le respect de nos engagements
internationaux
le projet de loi crée par ailleurs des
pôles régionaux compétents pour les
accidents collectifs l'expérience en
effet montré que la prise en charge
judiciaire des grandes catastrophes
pouvait s'avérer difficile par nature
ces événements peuvent survenir en tous
lieux de notre territoire et parfois
dans le ressort de petites juridictions
je pense par exemple au dramatique
incendie dans un tunnel du mont-blanc ou
à l'accident aérien du mont saint-odile
eu égard à leur ampleur et la technicité
des questions que soulèvent ces affaires
doivent pouvoir être instruite et jugés
par des juridictions spécialisées des
associations de victimes de ces
accidents avaient d'ailleurs appelé de
leurs voeux une telle évolution en
matière de médiation judiciaire le texte
procède
à une modification importante de la
justice militaire
c'est vraiment tribunal aux armées de
paris et en attribuant la juridiction
parisienne
anna juriste païenne pardon la
compétence aux infractions commises en
temps de paix hors du territoire de la
république par les membres des forces
armées ou à l'encontre de celle ci la
spécificité de la fraction des paniers
puisque celles ci seront jugés par les
formations du tribunal de grande
instance et de la cour d'appel de paris
spécialisée en matière militaire
cette mesure de cohérence et de
simplification est aussi important
symboliquement car elle finalise
l'intégration en temps de paix de la
justice militaire d'un justice de droit
commun comme vous l'avez est noté
monsieur le rapporteur cléac'h cette
réforme est bien accueilli tant par les
magistrats que les autres il ya justice
que par les militaires
la commission de la défense a en outre
saisi cette occasion pour procéder à des
clarifications
qu'ils s'agissent de la juridiction
compétente dans les faits commis à bord
d'un navire ou nf et de simplifier
également et harmoniser la définition de
la désertion l'effort de clarification
de notre organisation judiciaire se
double d'un effort de clarification des
procédures qui constitue le second axe
fort du projet les dispositions soumises
à votre examen apporte des allègements
de procédures tant en matière civile
qu'en matière pénale et ouvre de
nouvelles perspectives pour le règlement
rapide et efficace des contentieux qui
ne présente pas de difficultés
particulières
sassi que le texte permet de définir les
jeux etc sont compétentes pour connaître
des demandes formées en application de
deux règlements communautaires
restaurant une procédure d'injonction de
payer européenne une procédure de
règlement des petits litiges
par ailleurs afin de prendre acte d'un
récent arrêt de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
je vous proposerai une adaptation de
notre réglementation relative à
l'inscription des experts sur les listes
des juridictions
le texte étend également le champ des
procédures pénales simplifiées
cette mesure de rationalisation permet
notamment de réduire les délais de
jugement et par là même d'améliorer
la pédagogie de la fonction pénales
ainsi que l'a proposé la commission
guinchard le projet de loi prévoit de
développer le recours à l'ordonnancé
la comparution se reconnaissent
reconnaissance préalable de culpabilité
la procédure d'amande forfaitaire ou
encore la transaction pénale comme l'a
souligné très justement monsieur le
rapporteur detraigne le dispositif
permet de réserver des audiences
correctionnelles au contentieux les plus
complexes et les plus sensibles
le texte du gouvernement prévoyait que
la coopération se reconnaissance
préalable de culpabilité serait possible
pour tous les délits quelle que soit la
peine encourue
j'ai cependant pris acte que votre
commission avait souhaité exclure du
champ de nasser pc des violences
volontaires et involontaires contre les
personnes des menaces les agressions
sexuelles aggravées
une autre commission a plutôt été bien
inspiré contenu du texte que je
présenterai bientôt devant cela
l'ordonnancé pénale et pourra être
utilisée pour de nombreux délits d'une
gravité modérée autres que ceux portant
atteintes aux personnes
l'amendé forfaitaire sera étendu à
certaines contraventions de 5e classe et
la transaction à certaines infractions
en droit pénal de la santé publique en
droit de la consommation est en droit de
la concurrence
je sais que ces procédures provoque
certes à des réticences mais je ne
prends pas à 4 soit justifié cette
procédure autant d'effet fait la preuve
de leur efficacité et du souci constant
du respect du droit des personnes et de
la défense le plus si ces procédures
sont habituellement désignés sous le
terme de procédures simplifiées
je devais qualifierais plutôt pour ma
part de procédures accepté en effet
leurs caractéristiques communes et de ne
pouvoir prospérer que si la personne
poursuivie accepte la peine proposée par
le procureur de la république dans la
crpc décidée par le juge
à l'heure de danse pénale ou prévues par
la loi en cas d'amendé forfaitaire
or quand cela est possible il me semble
qu'une peine accepté et
toujours préférable à une peine imposée
il n'y a donc pas lieu de craindre ces
procédures qui sont entourés de
nombreuses garanties garantie que le
présent projet de loi renforce
sensiblement notamment pour leur donnant
ce pénale le texte prévoit enfin de
modifications importantes en matière de
divorce la première concerne le divorce
par consentement mutuel secondes
l'expérimentation du recours préalable
obligatoire à la médiation familiale
le projet du gouvernement reprend tout
d'abord une des recommandations phares
du rapport de la commission guinchard
qui avait été adopté à l'unanimité et de
ses membres il prévoit en effet que la
comparution personnelle des époux devant
le juge aux affaires familiales ne sont
plus obligatoires dans le seul cas du
divorce par consentement mutuel de
couples sans enfants mineurs encore
notre commission des lois a supprimé
cette disposition du projet aux yeux du
gouvernement pourtant cette disposition
était respectueuse des droits des
parties
je veux à cet égard souligné que le
contrôle du juge reste intacte
il devra évidemment dans tous les cas
s'assurer de l'intégrité du consentement
de chacun des époux et du respect des
intérêts de chacun d'entre eux dans la
convention de divorce
en outre l'accès au juge par les partis
sera de droit dès lors que la dépouille
fera la demande et le juge dès lors
qu'ils l'estimeront nécessaire pour a
aussi organisé cette comparution de sa
propre initiative
enfin la comparution des époux restera
obligatoire lorsque le juge envisagent
de refuser l'homologation de la
convention au fond la mesure
soigneusement encadré or à la vertu de
permettre au juge aux affaires
familiales se concentrer davantage sur
les cas les plus sensibles et plus
complexe
le projet de loi prévoit également une
plus grande transparence des prix
pratiqués en matière de divorce par
consentement mutuel
notre commission a souhaité aller plus
loin en généralisant l'obligation pour
l'avocat d'établir une convention
d'honoraires obligatoire dans tous les
cas de divorce
par ailleurs elle a souhaité maintenir à
juste titre un barème indicatif établi
par le garde des sceaux sur avis du
conseil national des barreaux
l'amendement que vous proposera
l'important viendra opportunément
précisé ce dispositif
enfin vous savez le gouvernement
s'attache à développer une véritable
culture de la médiation et de
conciliation
c'est dans cette perspective que projet
de loi propose d'expérimenter en matière
familiale
un dispositif de médiation obligatoire
avant toute saisine du juge sous peine
d'irrecevabilité de la demande
en effet la médiation qui permet de
renouer le dialogue entre parents
séparés facilite la conclusion d'accords
équilibrer la sensibilité du contentieux
familial rend d'autant plus nécessaire
la recherche de l'adhésion des parents
indispensable à la bonne exécution des
engagements pris ce dispositif
recommandée à l'unanimité par là
commission gâcheur ne s'appliquera que
lorsque le juge aura déjà statué une
première fois sur les modalités
d'exercice de l'autorité parentale ou
sur la contribution à l'entretien et à
l'éducation de l'enfant assis d'accès
direct aux juges n'est pas remis en
cause par l'expérimentation pour les cas
où il n'a jamais eu à connaître de la
situation d'une famille
par ailleurs la médiation préalable
obligatoire ne sera pas exigée dans deux
hypothèses soit lorsque les parents sont
d'accord sur les modifications
envisagées soit ce motif légitime
invoqué secrétaire permettra de répondre
à la diversité des situations qui
pourraient se présenter afin d'assurer
l'accès effectif aux juges votre
commission des lois a souhaité étendre
les dérogations ce dispositif au cas où
un parent déclarent ne pas s'opposer à
la demande de l'autre parent ou lorsque
la médiation ne peut être mise en oeuvre
dans un délai raisonnable et ses
rédactions me paraissent pouvoir être
précisées en effet si l'accord des
parties justifie pleinement de leur
éviter un recours à la médiation
ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas d'une
simple absence d'opposition de l'une
d'entre elles notamment si celle ci
n'est pas présentes ou représentées lors
de l'audience
c'est précisément le cadre de la
médiation qui permettra de s'assurer de
la réalité de l'absence d'opposition
d'arrière
la référence au délai raisonnable ne
semble pouvoir trouver sa place parmi
les motifs légitimes permettant l'accès
direct au juge je vous présenterai donc
un abonnement sur ces sujets certains
ont exprimé leurs craintes sur ce
nouveau dispositif
je ne crois utile équilibré tout d'abord
nous connaissons tous les limites du
tout judiciaire et les modes alternatifs
de règlement des conflits ont fait la
preuve de leur efficacité de leur
pertinence
ensuite l'expérimentation permettra de
tester l'efficacité de cette nouvelle
mesure est d'appréhender très
précisément les besoins et les
améliorations nécessaires à sa
généralisation
enfin je serai amené à vous présenter
d'autres amendements visant à abroger la
loi du 12 juillet 1909 relatives aux
biens de famille à saisissable resterait
un nouveau dispositif permettant
d'adapter le moment venu en accord avec
la profession le régime de la
postulation des avocats devant les tgi
en effet la modification cas par cas au
niveau de la loi de l'étendue du
monopole de postulation des différents
barreaux ne satisfait personne
comme l'expérience récente le montre
vous proposerai donc en lieu et place de
ce qui a été voté il ya quelques
semaines un dispositif solide qui
permettra de traiter ces questions dans
la sérénité la concertation dès lors que
vous l'aurez adopter assouplies
un des exigences de domiciliation enfin
en matière de célébration du mariage en
permettant désormais s'agit assiste
cette mesure notamment pour les petits
villages en permettant désormais que les
unions de nos enfants puissent être
célébrée dans les communes de résidence
de leurs parents
cet amendement répond demande forte des
élus et je suis heureux de pouvoir ou
l'a proposé la commission présidée par
le recteur guinchard appelait à
l'ambition d'une justice apaisée apaisé
pas justiciable apaisé pour tous les
acteurs judiciaires
aussi je crois que par ces avancées
nombreux le texte soumis à votre examen
constitue un pas significatif dans ce
sens paul justice qui soit mieux compris
plus accessible et qui grâce aux
allègements aux clarifications que nous
proposons
erasme fonctionnement substantiellement
améliorés cette ambition pour une
justice efficace et de qualité je le
sais est aussi la vôtre
le texte donne des clés pour y parvenir
je sais pouvoir compter sur la qualité
de vos débats pour donner toute leur
ampleur à ces évolutions
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur yves détraigne
rapporteur de la commission des lois
je
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
sommet chers collègues le projet de loi
relatif à la répartition des contentieux
et à l'allègement de certaines urgences
dictionnaire trouve essentiellement
inspiration dans leur rapport de l'être
de la répartition des contentieux
présidée par le recteur guinchard qui a
été remis au garde des sceaux en juin
2008 et dans plusieurs propositions ont
d'ailleurs déjà été reprise par le
parlement ce texte embrasse des sujets
très divers aussi divers que ceux dont
on connaît finalement chaque jour la
justice et ce nouveau mouvement de
simplification et d'allègement des
procédures intervient au moment où
l'institution judiciaire est confronté à
de profondes mutations
la réforme de la carte judiciaire
deux juridictions
va gérer une pénurie de moyens humains
et matériels
par exemple je les constate à plusieurs
reprises ces dernières années conduit à
supprimer dans les derniers mois de
l'année
les audiences des juges de proximité où
leurs participations qu'assesseur aux
formations que le juge alt est triple
faut tout simplement si je puis dire 2
et leur vacation cette situation doit
donc être prise en considération
lorsqu'il s'agit de modifier
l'organisation judiciaire ou d'alléger
les procédures car il importe de
vérifier que les mesures envisagées vont
bien se traduire par un meilleur
fonctionnement l'institution judiciaire
car c'est ça finalement l'objectif
si l'objectif d'efficacité et doit donc
être prise en compte
il ne doit pas pour autant conduire à
négliger des exigences aussi fondamental
que l'accès à la justice ou le droit à
un jugement dans un délai raisonnable
c'est donc dans cet esprit que votre
commission la commission des lois à
examiner ce projet j'évoquerai
principalement à cette tribune
quatre thèmes qui me paraissent
essentiels dans le projet même s'il ya
d'autres sujets qui sont examinées
d'abord la suppression de la juridiction
de proximité et la redéfinition des
missions du juge de proximité
ensuite la création de nouvelles
juridictions spécialisées puis
l'extension du recours aux procédures
rapides ou simplifié ou accepter comme a
dit le garde des sceaux de jugement et
enfin l'allègement des règles de
procédure dans le domaine familial donc
d'abord la suppression de la jeudi
et la redéfinition des missions du jus
timité le rapport guinchard
que la juridiction de proximité qui
avait été créée je vous le rappelle en
2002 2003 n'a pas atteint les objectifs
ambitieux qui lui avait été assigné en
justice
réconcilier avec
aussi cette commission at elle préconisé
puis au moins sable
en cette juridiction tout en reprenant
cette préconisation le gouvernement
propose cependant de maintenir les juges
de proximité en les rattachant au
tribunal de grande instance ce qui leur
permettrait de travailler au contact des
juges professionnels
cette réforme tend donc à maintenir les
fonctions de juge de proximité pour
statuer en matière pénale mais supprime
leurs compétences en matière de
contentieux civil le projet de loi
retire ainsi au juge de proximité leurs
compétences en matière de contentieux
civil relatifs aux actions personnelles
ou mobilières jusqu'à une valeur de 4000
euros mais ne leur retire pas leurs
compétences en matière pénale pour
statuer sur les contraventions des
quatre premières classes
la commission a considéré que
l'augmentation des moyens des tribunaux
d'instance constituer une condition
nécessaire à la suppression des
fonctions des juges de proximité au
contentieux civil en effet cette réforme
ne pourrait être mise en oeuvre sans que
des moyens supplémentaires soit accordée
aux tribunaux d'instance qui vont subir
du fait du départ des juges de proximité
le transfert de plus de 100000 affaires
civiles nouvelles
on peut d'ailleurs estimée à une
soixantaine d'emplois équivalents temps
pleins de magistrats les besoins des
tribunaux d'instance de ce fait j'ai
d'ailleurs monsieur le garde des sceaux
pouvoir vous entendre à ce sujet quand
nous l'aborderons la commission des lois
a également approuvé l'extension au tj
au tribunal de grande instance de la
procédure d'injonction de payer afin
tout simplement de simplifier l'exercice
de l'opposition par le défendeur lorsque
la requête en injonction de payer porte
sur un montant supérieur à 2000 euros
elle souhaite toutefois compléter cette
mesure pour assurer une procédure
uniforme dans ce domaine et ne pas
exposer les justiciables à des dépenses
supplémentaires dans la mesure la
présentation d'une requête devant le tgi
nécessite le recours un deuxième domaine
dans lequel je veux vous dire quelques
mots la création de nouvelles
juridictions spécialisées
le projet
créer de nouvelles auditions spécialisés
afin de renforcer l'efficacité
l'efficacité pardon de notre justice
pénale dans des contentieux qui se
distingue particulièrement par leur
complexité leur technicité se presser à
judy fait pour les crimes contre
l'humanité et les crimes de guerre au
sein du tgi de paris d'une part et des
juridictions spécialisées pour les
accidents collectifs dire les grandes
catastrophes d'autre part la commission
a souhaité étendre la compétence et les
moyens du nouveau pôle judiciaire
spécialisé pour les crimes contre
l'humanité elle a en effet voulu
attribuer compétences d'une part en
matière de crimes et délits guerre qui
ont été inscrits dans notre code pénal
en 2010 et d'autre part en matière de
crimes de torture telles que ceux visés
par la convention de new york du 10
décembre 1984 elle a également voulu me
permettre d'utiliser les mesures
d'investigation que le code de procédure
pénale prévoit aujourd'hui pour le pôle
spécialisé en matière de kimi la
criminalité organisée et de terrorisme
tels que l'infiltration ou la
sonorisation
la commission a par ailleurs adopté une
disposition visant à faciliter les
investigations à l'étranger des
magistrats chargés de l'instruction de
ces crimes et délits afin de leur
permettre de conduire eux-mêmes dans le
cadre d'une commission rogatoire
internationale
l'audition des témoins dans un état
étranger
j'ajoute monsieur mini ce qu'il paraît
en outre indispensable à votre
commission qu'une équipe de magistrats
qui se consacrer exclusivement à ce type
d'affaires et que des enquêteurs
spécialement consacré aux crimes contre
l'humanité et crimes de guerre soient
mis à sa disposition par ailleurs en
complément à la création de jeudi sont
spécialisés en matière d'accidents
collectifs
la commission des lois a inséré deux
articles additionnels précisant les
dispositions permettant aux associations
et fait dire fédération d'associations
défendant les victimes d'accidents
collectifs d'obtenir des
dommages-intérêts et des dommages et
intérêts troisième thème la commission
des lois a souhaité préciser l'extension
du recours aux procédures simplifiées de
jus
comment le projet de loi propose
d'étendre le champ de 3 procédure pénale
simplifiée l'ordonnancé pénale
la procédure de comparution sur
reconnaissance préalable de culpabilité
crpc et le système contraventionnelle si
les procédures simplifiées de traitement
des affaires pénales se sont bien
développées et permettent de réserver
les audiences correctionnelles au
contentieux les plus complexes où les
plus sensibles à les rappeler une
solitaire du 10 où elles se doivent
néanmoins de concilier les droits de la
défense et les droits de la victime
à cet égard la commission a approuvé les
dispositions du projet de loi tendant à
étendre de façon limitée le champ de ses
procédures sous réserve toutefois de
plusieurs aménagements dans un souci de
pédagogie de la réponse pénale et afin
de mieux prévenir la récidive
la commission a précisé que l'
ordonnance pénale ne pourra pas être
utilisée lorsque les fai auront été
commis en état de récidive légale
par ailleurs elle a souhaité que la
procédure de crpc qui est étendue pour
certaines infractions punies de peine
supérieure à cinq ans d'emprisonnement
matière de trafic de stupéfiants ou
d'escroquerie par exemple ne puisse pas
non plus être utilisé dans les cas
d'atteintes les plus graves aux
personnes
en effet le préjudice suivi par la
victime dans de telles affaires suppose
que la culpabilité de la personne mise
en cause puisse est systématiquement
discuter contradictoirement devant le
tribunal correctionnel
la crpc offrant un outil utile pour le
règlement d'affaires dans lesquelles
l'auteur des faits reconnaît sa
responsabilité et accepte la sanction
proposée
votre commission a en outre souhaité
autoriser sa mise
et avec l'accord de l'ensemble des
partis lorsque les faits reprochés à la
personne mise en examen constituait un
délit sur la proposition d'extension de
la procédure de forfaitisation
contraventions de 5ème catégorie
la commission des lois a émis un avis
favorable mais elle a souhaité cependant
en exclure celles les contraventions qui
deviennent un délit lorsqu'elles sont
commises en état de récidive légale sur
la transaction pénale enfin votre
commission a estimé que le recours à
cette procédure dans certains
contentieux techniques permettront en
effet d'offrir à l'autorité
administrative habilitée à engager des
poursuites
un outil de réponse efficace et
dissuasif sous le contrôle du parquet
c'est pourquoi elle a souhaité étendre
le champ de cette procédure d'une pam en
matière de droit de la concurrence et de
la consommation et d'autre part en
matière de lutte contre le tabagisme et
l'alcoolisme
quatrième point sur lequel je vous
raciste et l'allègement des règles de
procédures en matière familiale
la commission des lois a rejeté la
disposition dispensant de comparution
devant le juge aux affaires familiales
les couples sans enfants mineurs dans le
cadre du divorce par consentement mutuel
l'article 13 du projet de loi ça a été
rappelée prévoyait en effet que ces
derniers n'auraient plus à comparaître
personnellement et systématiquement
devant le juge la commission considère
que la réforme de 2004 et déjà allés
très loin en matière de simplification
procédurales pour les parties ainsi la
durée moyenne de l'audience aujourd'hui
tout face comprise d'etel plus que de 20
des tales plus que de 20 à 25 minutes
il me paraît nécessaire que la
séparation d'un couple marié soit
entouré je dirais d'une certaine
solennité symétrique de celle du mariage
qui n'est pas l'union libre ni le pacs
quand bien même les parties se seraient
entendues sur tous les aspects de leur
divorce
car le divorce pas plus que le mariage
n'est un acte banal et ne doit pas le
devenir
par ailleurs l'entrevue des époux avec
le jus
permet à celui-ci de s'assurer de la
réalité du consentement de chacun des
conjoints de l'absence de contraintes
plus ou moins directe pesant et de sa
compréhension des effets du divorce tel
au cul avec l'autre partie les
organisent l'accueil ici à tenir des
procédures garantissant l'équilibré
entre les parties et l'accès effectif à
un juge dans le cadre divorce par
consentement mutuel en outre à 14 qui
est relatif à la régulation à un avocat
pour la procédure de divorce parcours la
commission a voulu améliorer la
prévisibilité prévisibilité des
honoraires acquittés
elle a donc choisi un dispositif plus
contraignant les conciliable avec la
liberté de fixation des honoraires la
convention d'honoraires serait
obligatoire pour toutes les procédures
de divorce ce qui reste compatible avec
la liberté contractuelle mais les
justiciables pourrait s'appuyer sur un
barème indicatif élaboré par la
chancellerie
en collaboration avec le conseil
national des barreaux à partir des
usages observé ce point pourra
d'ailleurs être précisés lors de nos
débats
la commission a par ailleurs encadrer
l'expérimentation proposait pour trois
ans de l'obligation de recourir à la
médiation familiale pour les actions
tendant à faire modifier les modalités
d'exercice de l'autorité parentale
fixées à une décision de justice j'ai
bien entendu ce qu'a dit juste avant moi
monsieur le garde des sceaux la
médiation familiale c'est une très bonne
chose mais la saisine du juge aux fins
de modification des de ces mesures
devraient donc c'est selon projet doit
être précédée à peine d'irrecevabilité
par une tentative de médiation sauf si
les parents sont d'accord sur les
modifications envisagées ou si un motif
légitime justifie une saisine directe du
juge le développement de la médiation je
les dis est une bonne chose mais ce
développement requiert des moyens
importants qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de la seule
expérimentation qui est envisagé sur
cinq départements
si mes calculs sont bons 5169 dossiers
qui sont actuellement traitées
directement par le juge
c'est génial devrait faire l'objet d'une
médiation préalable
l'expérimentation nécessiterait donc à
elle seule de l'ordre de 100 3
équivalent temps plein de médiateurs
familiaux supplémentaires en cas de
généralisation sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
il serait nécessaire de recruter
l'équivalent de plus de 1700 emplois
temps plein travaillés de médiateur soit
six fois l'effectif actuel la commission
a donc souhaité éviter qu'un allongement
des délais pour obtenir un rendez-vous
dans un service de médiation familiale
qui n'auraient pas les moyens de
répondre aux attentes ne retarde
excessivement le règlement du conflit
qui ne pourrait pendant ce temps que
sont venus mais encore plus c'est
pourquoi la commission a précisé que
l'obligation de médiation préalable
pourrait être écarté ce qui compte tenu
des délais dans lesquels la médiation
est susceptible d'intervenir les parties
court le risque d'être coupé de leur
droit d'accéder au juge dans un délai
raisonnable elle a en outre souhaité
exempter les parents de l'obligation de
médiation au préalable lorsqu'il dépose
conjointement une demande de décision
relative aux modalités d'exercice de
l'autorité parentale ou lorsque l'un des
deux a déposé la demande et que l'autre
ne s'y opposent pas voilà madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues les principales
modifications que la commission des lois
a souhaité apporter à ce texte
fier des mesures intéressantes est
vraiment dans le sens d'une
clarification et d'une amélioration du
fonctionnement de notre justice
encore faut-il veiller à sauvegarder
l'équilibré entre les mesures proposées
et les moyens qui seront consacrés à
leur mise en oeuvre et faire en sorte
que la simplification des procédures
juridictionnelles ne se traduisent pas
par une banalisation de certaines
d'entre elles qui amoindrirait leur
impact
c'est ce à quoi la commission des lois
s'est efforcé de veiller tout au long de
l'examen de ce projet je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur marcel pierre cléac'h
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères
la présidente monsieur le garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées du sénat
a souhaité se saisir pour avis des
articles 23 24 et 26 du projet de loi
qui concerne la justice militaire
en accord avec le président et le
rapporteur de la commission des lois que
je tiens à remercier notre commission a
ainsi reçu une délégation au fond pour
ces trois articles
le projet de loi prévoit de supprimer le
tribunal aux armées de paris qui est
compétent pour
infractions commises par ou à l'encontre
des mets à l'étranger en temps de paix
il s'inscrit ainsi dans le prolongement
des précédents de réformes de la justice
militaire notamment la loi de 1982
présenté par notre collègue euros alors
garde des sceaux qui aimait
nos militaires sur le territoire de la
république
et la compétence aux juridictions de
droit commun spécialisés la suppression
du tribunal aux armées de paris et le
transfert de ses attributions à la
formation spécialisée du tgi de paris
marquerait donc l'achèvement de
l'intégration de la justice militaire
dans la justice de droit commun en temps
de paix déjà napoléon considéré qu on
est citoyen français avant d'être soldat
et clemenceau estimé que la justice
militaire est à la justice ce que la
musique militaire est à la musique un
peu méchant comme je précise que cette
réforme ne vise que le temps de paix et
qu'en temps de guerre le code de justice
militaire prévoit le rétablissement des
tribunaux militaires
je ne cacherai pas que j'étais au départ
assez réservé sur cette réforme
par crainte d'une moindre prise en
compte de la spécificité militaire
devant les juridictions ordinaires
toutefois ma position a évolué au fur à
mesure de mes auditions
je suis désormais rassuré sur ce point
principaux arguments militent en ce sens
tout d'abord le tribunal aux armées de
paris n'a de militaires que le nom
puisqu'il est composé exclusivement de
magistrats civils et qu'ils appliquent
le code de procédure pénale ensuite
armées de paris reste une juridiction
hybride ministère de la défense et les
mains
dépendance et de partialité de cette
juridiction
de plus elles ne tiennent pas compte de
l'est au dessus de la magistrature et
surtout de la jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme enfin
le volume d'activité de cette
juridiction est très faible
le tribunal aux armées de paris reçoit
environ 1600 à 1700 procédure et
prononce entre 180 et 190 jugement par
an la suppression de cette juridiction
serait donc source de simplification et
de rationalisation
comme j'ai pu le constater lors de mes
auditions cette réforme est accueillie
très très favorablement par les
militaires en effet à leurs yeux ce
décompte c'est moins le maintien d'une
juridiction spécialisée dont la
dimension militaire et surtout déjà
symbolique que la prise en compte de la
spécificité militaire
cette spécificité tient en particulier à
l'avis préalable du ministre de la
défense avant avant l'engagement de
poursuites à l'encontre d'un militaire
et à l'impossibilité pour la victime de
faire citer directement un militaire
devant une juridiction de jugement
or ces règles particulières serait
maintenue avec la réforme titre
anecdotique je préciserai que le
tribunal aux armées de paris a son siège
dans une caserne militaire celle de
reuilly diderot que je connais bien
puisque j'y ai séjourné plusieurs
plusieurs mois pendant mon service
militaire
on peut partir en algérie or le
ministère de la défense s'est engagé à
céder cette caserne à la ville de paris
afin d'y construire des logements
sociaux tout en approuvant cette réforme
et en inspirant la proposition de loi
que j'avais déposé au sénat
j'ai proposé cinq amendements à notre
commission qui les a adoptés à
l'unanimité
nous avons ainsi estimé indispensable de
prévoir l'avis du ministre
lorsqu'un militaire et susceptibles
d'être poursuivis à la suite d'une
plainte contre x d'une plainte avec
constitution de partie civile ou à
l'occasion d'un réquisitoire supplétif
cet avis est un élément très important
car il permet d'apporter un éclairage
sur des situations opérationnelles
complexe notamment en opérations
extérieures comme en afghanistan par
exemple
je rappelle que cet avis
encadré dans le délai d'un mois est un
simple avis consultatif qui ne nie pas
le procureur de la république
nous avons ainsi clarifier les
compétences concernant les infractions
commises
nous avons aussi clarifier les
compétences concernant les infractions
commises à bord des navires ou des
aéronefs militaires
en outre nous avons souhaité simplifier
la définition de la désertion
contrairement ce que l'on aurait pu
penser la professionnalisation des
armées ne s'est pas traduite par une
diminution des cas de désertion bien au
contraire
d'après les données du ministère de la
défense les désertions augmenté ont
augmenté de 500% en dix ans les
juridictions sont donc inondé de cas de
désertion qui la plupart du temps ne
font pas l'objet de condamnations nous
avons donc souhaité clarifier et
harmoniser la définition de la désertion
qu'elle intervienne sur le territoire ou
à l'étranger
enfin nous avons souhaité faire quelques
observations ainsi nous pensons monsieur
le garde des sceaux qui serait utile que
le ministère de la justice lance une
réflexion sur l'idée d'un regroupement
des juridictions de droit commun
spécialisé en deux ou trois pôles
spécialisés en matière militaire
ce regroupement aurait en effet le
mérite de renforcer la centralisation
des affaires militaires et la
spécialisation des magistrats devrait
également insister sur la formation des
magistrats en effet compte tenu de la
professionnalisation des armées mais
aussi de la féminisation de la
magistrature
il me paraît indispensable de renforcer
la formation des magistrats aux affaires
militaires à le nm ou par des stages par
ailleurs je voudrais vous faire part mon
inquiétude sur l'avenir du corps des
greffiers militaire s'est greffé
militaires qui sont souvent d'anciens
militaires apportent en effet une
expertise précieuse au juge chargé de
ces affaires
il serait utile à mes yeux d'engager une
réflexion sur l'avenir de ce corps en
voie d'extinction
enfin compte tenu des difficultés
matière et matériel actuel de la justice
il me semble que cette réforme devrait
s'accompagner d'un transfert en terme de
personnels et de moyens de la part du
ministère de la défense au ministère de
la justice
je pense notamment aux frais de
fonctionnement du tribunal qui sont
relativement limités mais aussi aux
frais de justice qui peuvent représenter
un montant assez élevées en matière
militaire
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et les forces armées vous
recommande donc l'adoption des articles
23 24 et 26 du projet de loi tel que
modifié et complété par les amendements
qu'elle a adoptée je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à madame la présidente nicole
borvo cohen seat pour le groupe crc spg
madame la présidente monsieur garde des
sceaux chers collègues alors c'est à
nouveau un texte fourre tout que vous me
présentez monsieur garde les sous je le
dis tout de suite ne voteront pas et
pour plusieurs raisons la moindre
n'étant pas le contexte dans lequel ce
débat intervient ce texte veut mail et
cela devienne trop fréquent au parlement
des dispositions disparates comme ça
leur nature ou un enjeu qu'elle recouvre
ce qu'il soit dit en passant
mail forcément des choses avec
lesquelles on est d'accord mais
malheureusement d'autres lesquels on ne
l'est pas et qui sont beaucoup plus
préoccupante après d'autres textes avant
celui ci il a surtout pour objet de
décliner des propositions émises par la
commission guinchard
donc on l'a déjà dit à d'autres
occasions
on fait des réformes par petits bouts
sauf que je le crains ça consiste cela
consiste à masquer les enjeux actuels en
matière de fonctionnement de la justice
d'ailleurs le rapport guinchard avait un
objectif clair puisqu'il disait c'est un
rapport qui se veut globale en ce sens
qu'il envisage la répartition des
contentieux dans une cohérence totale
avec la réforme de la carte judiciaire
or comme vous le savez nous n'avons pas
été d'accord avec la réforme de la carte
judiciaire et je veux pas y revenir ici
mais évidemment et tout ça aussi une
cohérence je veux dire la cohérence
existe aussi chez ceux qui s'opposent à
vos réformes alors elles sont les
réformes sont pas allés de pair dans le
temps mais est effectivement elles sont
cohérentes et quand même la grande
cohérence de tout ça c'est la volonté de
gérer les moyens indigents de service
public de la justice
il suffit de lire l'exposé des motifs ou
l'étude d'impact ce qu'on y trouve la
rationalisation l'allègement la
spécialisation la simplification des
procédures personnes dit comme ça on
pourrait dire oui il faut effectivement
rationaliser alléger ça dépend
spécialisé là aussi ça dépend et
simplification pareil donc par contre il
n'y a pas d'ambition pour l'institution
judiciaire
la réforme de la carte judiciaire avait
pour objet de faire mais un nombre
important de tribunaux s'est réalisé 178
tribunaux d'instance 17 tribunaux de
grande instance supprimés c'est donc une
régression du service public de la
justice que le projet de loi bien
entendu accompagne le noble le dogme est
encore la réduction de dépenses
publiques et l'application l'air gpp
quelles que soient les conséquences sur
les justiciables
ce projet a été déposé sur le bureau du
sénat il ya déjà plus d'un an donc déjà
se pose une question pourquoi tout à
coup
yat-il nécessité de mettre l'urgence
et de le faire voter à toute force au
parlement qu'est ce que ça signifie
au moment même où l'institution
judiciaire connaît une crise profonde
l'urgence réelle n'est t'elle pas de
répondre au cri d'alarmé lancé par les
professionnels de la justice
nul n'ignore que 5000 d'entre eux
manifester à paris et dans toute la
france le 29 mars dans la diversité de
leur statut une première d'ailleurs
j'étais à leurs côtés et je peux en
témoigner
vous le savez bien monsieur le garde des
sceaux la situation des tribunaux est
tout simplement catastrophique pour
beaucoup je dis pas de partout mais
hélas dans beaucoup d'endroits certains
n'ont plus de quoi ouvrir le courrier
d'autres de faire des photocopies
enfin bref d'autres d'envoyer les actes
enfin voila vous resté sourd à cette
réalité et je crois qu'on ne réglera
rien s'en prendre à bras le corps la
question prégnante des moyens de la
justice
on ne réglera rien en multipliant des
réformes partielles destinées à masquer
le fond du problème
promouvoir une justice plus efficace
plus rapide comme vous aimez le dire
suppose des moyens sauf à renoncer à
l'ambition d'une justice égale pour tous
voilà égalité et réductions ne peuvent
pas se concilier aujourd'hui certes vous
avez renonce vous avez annoncé par dont
la création de 485 poste non seulement
c'est bien en dessous des besoins mais
vous les avez immédiatement affectées à
la mise en oeuvre de vos futures
réformes et ils ne sont de toute façon
pas prévu au budget le présent projet de
loi s'inscrit dans cette logique
avec pour déclinaison la
déjudiciarisation la centralisation la
spécialisation qui devient un postulat
on a le sentiment que peu à peu le
service public de la justice
s'organisera autour de quelques grands
pôles d expertise le sentiment aussi
d'assister avec ce projet de loi à une
sorte de jeu de dominos pour la deuxième
fois depuis sa création en 2002 vous
réformer la justice de proximité
il s'agissait alors d'ajouter une
troisième juridique
de premier instance otg et aux tribunaux
d'instance le groupe crc s'y était
opposé nous avions soulevé un risque de
confusion avec l'installation d'un
nouvel ordre judiciaire
cette crainte je le rappelle était aussi
celle de nos collègues jean pierre
schosteck à l'époque et pierre fauchon
rapporteur et c'est aujourd'hui vous qui
parlait de confusion notre position
était claire la juridiction de proximité
ce sont les tribunaux d'instance les
juges de proximité ce sont les juges
d'instance
plutôt que de les doter de moyens
nécessaires à leur fonctionnement
majorité et gouvernement ont préféré
leur retirer des compétences au profit
des nouveaux juges de proximité à
l'époque avant d'en supprimer avec la
nouvelle carte judiciaire en 2005 que
les juges de proximité ont vu leurs
compétences élargies ce qui a modifié
leur rôle vers un contentieux de masse
cela sans que le bilan promis rappelez
vous fait vous n'étiez pas garde des
sceaux mais vous avez la mémoire
historique des gouvernements la même
majorité en quelque sorte et bilan n'a
jamais été fait aujourd'hui vous est
supprimée et vous voulez supprimer la
juridiction de proximité rattacher les
juges de proximité au tribunal de grande
instance
évidemment puisqu'il ya de moins en
moins des tribunaux d'instance il est
clair les difficultés actuelles ne
seront pas résolus puisque ils
exerceront toujours des attributions
tribunal d'instance et au tgi au civil
et au pénal
vous dites qu'ils ne seront pas en
situation de sujétion par rapport au
président du tgi avoir c'est lui qui
pourra décider de leur affectation en
fonction des besoins de sa juridiction
de fait ils compenseront pour une part
l'insuffisance en nombre des juges
professionnels
ce projet de loi procède à une nouvelle
répartition des compétences dans des
domaines très divers voie ferrée
préjudice lié au classement des objets
au titre des monuments historiques
objet laissé en gage par les voyageurs
au sommaire gistau hôteliers et j'en
passe quelle visibilité justifia fiable
peut-il attendre de la loi avec intel
fatras de modifications au coup par coup
vous fait de la spécialisation une règle
là
si dans des domaines disparates des
partitions prud'homale et ce sans
prévoir des moyens supplémentaires pour
les tg 3 de la propriété industrielle
avec l'objectif de donner une compétence
nationale otg une paris comptant ce
douanier que vous rattachez au tj quant
aux juridictions spécialisées en matière
d'accidents collectifs
je m'interroge sur leur pertinence
j'entends bien que la complexité de ce
contentieux exige des moyens
d'investigation et de jugement important
mais je ne suis pas certaine que la
spécialisation à outrance soit la bonne
réponse
sur le pôle compétent en matière de
crimes contre l'humanité ne croyez vous
pas qu'une telle disposition aurait
mérité beaucoup mieux que d'être noyé au
sein d'un texte fourre-tout dès la
première lecture la première heure
pardon nous avons approuvé la
perspective de ce dispositif annoncé il
ya plus d'un an
à grand renfort de presse d'ailleurs par
madame alliot marie et monsieur kouchner
sont plus là pour en parler nous
partagions évidemment l'objectif affiché
je cite patrie des droits de l'homme la
france ne sera jamais un sanctuaire pour
les auteurs de génocide de crimes de
guerre ou de crimes contre l'humanité
écrivait-il permettez-moi quelques
réserves quant à cette détermination
rappelez vous mes chers collègues quand
cette tribune est parue dans le monde le
gouvernement tribune des précédents le
gouvernement tergiverser encore sur le
deuxième projet de loi d'adaptation de
notre droit pénal à l'institution de la
cpi le texte alors en navette
adoptée en juillet dernier offre une
quasi impunité aux auteurs présumés de
crimes internationaux présents sur le
territoire français il leur suffit de ne
pas faire de la france leur résidence
habituelle c'est facile sans compter
d'autres verrou procéduraux
j'éprouve donc une crainte le nouveau
pôle spécialisé sera-t-il en mesure de
répondre aux intentions affichées les
dispositions juridiques seront elles à
la hauteur de ce que devrait être
l'exigence notre pays en matière de
crimes internationaux
je note d'ailleurs que si l'intitulé de
l'article 16 du présent projet évoqué
les crimes de guerre ils avaient été
oubliés
et après dans le texte il est de ce
point de vue très positif que notre
amendement fin mai le rapporteur et nous
avions un amendement dans ce sens est
permis de viser clairement les crimes de
guerre et de torture dans le texte
oublie peut-être non significatif mais
oublie quand même j'espère désormais
monsieur le ministre que vous même et le
gouvernement sauront vous attachez
adopté ce pôle des ressources des moyens
nécessaires à sa mission
ce projet de loi porte aussi sur le
droit de la famille
je rejoins notre rapporteur qui a
proposé de supprimer l'article 13 je
pense en effet qu'il n'est pas prudent
pour les garanties des parties des
cartes et l'intervention du juge en
matière de divorce par consentement
mutuel
même en l'absence d'enfants mineurs le
consentement mutuel
hélas cash quelquefois info consentement
quant à l'expérimentation de
l'obligation de recourir à peine de
nullité de la procédure à la médiation
familiale en cas de saisine du juge pour
l'exercice de l'autorité familiale elle
pose des problèmes importants
le problème du consentement tout d'abord
pour les mêmes raisons que précédemment
le problème du financement si cette
mesure devait se généraliser
nul doute qu'il posera pour beaucoup sur
les justiciables
il manquera 1700 médiateurs familiaux si
la mesure était généralisé il semble
évident qu'un marché privé de la
médiation va pouvoir se développer
ce que je déplore complètement vous
procédez aussi dans ce texte à une
extension très large des procédures
simplifiées tout particulièrement
l'ordonnancé pénale et la comparution
avec reconnaissance préalable de
culpabilité qui n'est pas pudiquement
appelée plaider coupable nous y sommes
cette fois encore totalement opposé nous
refusons cette démarche qui consiste à
produire toujours plus de condamnations
dans un temps toujours plus réduits et
avec toujours moins de garanties pour
les justiciables
avec ces procédures sont mises en cause
une pluralité de droit celui à un débat
contrat
victoire à la publicité des audiences à
l'impartialité du juge à
l'individualisation de la peine
vous aimez dire que qu'il faut tenir
compte des victimes
mais précisément le droit au débat
contradictoire par exemple est aussi un
droit pour les victimes
et vous continuez de ne pas répondre à
la question d'une meilleure prise en
compte de leurs démarches et de leur
accueil
mais évidemment là encore cela demande
beaucoup plus de moyens que la justice
n'en a aujourd'hui
vous dites que les droits sont garantis
puisque l'accusé acceptera la sanction
proposée mais mettez-vous à sa place
bien souvent dans les faits quel choix
aura-t-il non mes chers collègues le
justiciable n'y gagne pas avec un
traitement plus rapide de sa procédure
la justice a besoin de solennité
il faut leur toujours le répéter comme
elle a besoin de temps pour garantir le
respect des droits fondamentaux des
justiciables et je ne voudrais dire
aussi des victimes sauf à la rendre plus
lisible et plus inaccessibles et s'il
faut en effet désengorger les tribunaux
ce ne peut être qu'avec moins de textes
sécuritaires et des moyens adéquats
le recours au juge ne peut pas être
considérée comme un problème de coût à
réduire pour les finances publiques
il est de par son statut garant d'une
justice équitable au nom du peuple pour
laquelle il la rend il ne peut pas le
faire dans la précipitation
là évidemment dans ce texte vient de la
suppression on va dire je mets des
guillemets de la justice militaire nous
y sommes totalement favorables bon je
crois que ce texte abouti est un
aboutissement de ce qui n'a pu aboutir
en 1982 et c'était dommage à l'époque
l'armée s'y étaient opposés vous vous le
rappeler pour ceux qui ont connu cette
époque
aujourd'hui nous sommes tout à fait
favorables
évidemment à la suppression du tribunal
des armées de paris mais je le regrette
le fait d'être d'accord est tout à fait
d'accord avec ça ne peut pas sur le
texte d'autres questions que je viens
d'évoquer ce projet confirme
l'appréciation formulées par le
médiateur de la république dans son
dernier rapport des politiques brouillé
par l'empilement législatif
ce texte constitue un empilement
législatif en lui même et avec l'aval de
la majorité de la commission des lois le
gouvernement en rajoute avec cette
dizaine d'articles additionnels nous
demande donc carrément leur suppression
sous pression parce que c'est pas une
méthode de gouvernement
ce projet qui plus est va être suivie de
texte que vous amenez d'annoncer que
vous savez présenter monsieur le garde
des sceaux au conseil des ministres
là aussi supposé devoir être adoptée à
la hâte avant la fin de la session
parlementaire comme donc réforme des
jurés avec la création des jurés que
vous appelez populaire avec là aussi un
brouillage à prévoir avez vous réfléchi
par exemple au fonctionnement d'audience
correctionnelle où vont se côtoyer juge
professionnel juge de proximité
assesseurs citoyens totalement ignorants
des procédures correctionnelles réformer
la justice doit avant pour objectif
d'améliorer le service rendu aux
justiciables en n'oubliant pas la perse
les personnes les plus démunies des plus
modestes qui doivent pouvoir elles aussi
accéder au service public de la justice
or nombre de dispositions de ce projet
de loi prenne le chemin inverse
nous sommes à mille lieues du débat à
avoir sur les évolutions de notre
système judiciaire
l'indépendance des magistrats du parquet
la question du maintien d'une
instruction indépendante les conditions
précisément d'un rapprochement de la
justice des citoyens ou encore la
nécessité d'une justice spécifique des
mineurs à laquelle on entendait encore
donné un coup de canif grave
et voilà nous sommes à mille lieues de
ce débat sur les moyens qu'il est urgent
d'accorder au service public de la
justice au civil comme au pénal pour
qu'il fonctionne donc examiner ce projet
dans la situation de crise profonde où
est aujourd'hui notre institution
judiciaire est tout à fait pour nous
inacceptable donc nous voterons contre
ce texte
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à monsieur jean pierre michel
pour le groupe socialiste la présidente
monsieur garde des sceaux mme cyr
collègues nous vivons là en ce moment
une véritable provocation
et ceci à trois points de vue dont vous
n'êtes pas complètement responsable
personnellement monsieur le garde des
sceaux
tout d'abord la provocation c'est les
conditions dans lesquelles nous
discutions d'un texte d'un texte de
procédure pénale qui est un texte
compliqué comme tous les textes
procédure pénale les travaux de la
commission des lois le montre mais comme
tous les tests procédure pénale depuis
quelques années c'est la procédure
d'urgence
la procédure accélérée c'est à dire
qu'on n'est ce pas au parlement faire
son travail et l'expérience montre que
sur ces textes de procédure pénale
plusieurs lectures à l'assemblée et au
sénat sont parfois nécessaires pour
éviter des erreurs etc
or là il n'est pas question ce texte en
plus a été déposé il ya plus d'un an
il vient aujourd'hui ce soit mon
qualifierais pas le moment où il vient
pour quelles raisons pour quelle raison
y at il une urgence particulière
moi personnellement je n'en vois pas
deuxième provocation
le contexte comme cela a été dit avant
moi dans lequel ce texte vient il vient
au milieu de plusieurs autres textes
déposés par votre ministère et à cet
égard je pense monsieur le garde des
sceaux que vous auriez été mieux avisée
d'écouter les recommandations du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature qui
notamment ce qui concerne la récidive
mais aussi en général
en extrapolant vous recommande de ne pas
accélérer la production législative de
cette façon là pour permettre aux
tribunaux et aux personnels de justice
de la digérer
si je dire d'autre part on le sait très
bien la garde à vue vient d'être votée
déjà on dit le premier ministre lui même
d'ailleurs que c'est un texte n'aboutit
qu'on pourra peut-être pas l'appliquer
qu'il faudra peut-être le revoir enfin
bon on entend des choses absolument
incroyable je pars on nous demande on se
trouve
bon ils veulent être appliquée vous
présentez aux côtés des ministres un
texte encore une fois procédure
accélérée évidemment comme ça le
parlement ne fera pas son travail
khiêm bouleverse totalement la procédure
correctionnelle qui pour verser
également la procédure d'assises et qui
contrairement aux derniers avis du
conseil constitutionnel éloigne le droit
des mineurs de son autonomie pour le
rapprocher le droit des majeures on
verra ce qu'en pensent les conseils que
lionel lorsqu'il sera c'est également ce
texte interviennent dans on a dit george
iny revient pas dans un dur un malaise
profond quand même des institutions
judiciaires
même si vous essayez de calme et
l'émotion des magistrats et du personnel
peut-être que personnellement vous
réussissez mais dans le gouvernement
vous trouvez et avec l'elysée au dessus
vous ne réussissez vraiment pas
troisièmement sur le fond du texte
lui-même
en effet si l'on veut comprendre
pourquoi ce texte arrive si vite
pour quelles raisons eh bien il faut
examiner l'état de la justice
aujourd'hui et en tirer les conclusions
alors l'état de l'institution du je vais
pas pour ne pas allonger trône au débat
je vais pas faire une litanie
mais enfin quand même monsieur le garde
des sceaux dernièrement les cours
d'appel vous l'aurez vu notifier un
abaissement très important des crédits
affectés aux salles alors rémunération
de tous les auxiliaires et donc les
codes après le prennent des décisions
brutales et drastiques dans des
renouvellements non renouvellement de
contrats de vacataires suppressions de
postes à cette injustice réduction des
vacations des postes de proximité dans
certaines régions leur quasi disparition
on sait que certains tribunaux ne
peuvent plus payer leurs experts ben
vous me direz vous maîtrisez le
contraire comme écrire et le contraire
on sait que certains tribunaux comme
celui de nice ne peut plus payer deux
experts que à orléans avesnes sur helpe
à la rochelle amiens à tour il ya un
blocage des juridictions
alors tout ceci bien entendu c'est la
vérité et pire encore la direction des
avis judiciaire a indiqué le 17 février
dernier lors d'une réunion concernant
l'application de la de pénal de casio
paix que les vacataires qui serait
rémunéré de traiter en priorité au
développement du logiciel ce qui aboutit
évidemment à priver les autres cervidés
renfort attendent donc les tutelle etc
les grèves correctionnelle notamment
celui de paris n'auront pas les renforts
attendus et continueront à ne pas
pouvoir récupérer les milliers d'heures
supplémentaires qu'ils ont effectué tout
ceci également fait que comme vous a
laissé des annonces vous avez fait des
annonces un journal ouest france
après une certaine un certain trouble
ces annonces il faut le prendre pour ce
qu'elles sont c'est à dire des annonces
ministérielles
voilà c'est tout quine des annonces qui
ne sont censés faire plaisir qu'à ceux
qui les écoutent
quant à ceux qui les profèrent ils
savent très bien que l sont des annonces
complètement en l'air car les crédits
que vous avez annoncé soit ils sont pas
budgétée soit sont affectés aux jurés
auprès des des tribunaux correctionnels
et donc ils ne pourront pas vraiment
soulagée et alléger le travail
aujourd'hui des tribunaux
j'ajoute que la garde à vue les jurés
populaires la nécessité pour les ij de
contrôler les capitalisations d'office
bientôt dans le vote 90 certes pas le
gouvernement qui l'a voulu sceller
conseil constitutionnel tout ceci ne
fera qu'accentuer encore le malaise
alors on voit bien que les dispositions
de ce projet de loi les plus
contestables
sous couvert d'allègement des procédures
sont essentiellement destinés à pallier
la perte la pénurie les personnels au
mépris de quelques principes essentiels
comme le respect du contradictoire et la
publicité l'audience et sur ses succès
sur les deux points seulement que je
voudrais faire porter mon propos la
supprime tout d'abord la suppression de
la juridiction de proximité
bon créé par la loi perben nous avions
voté contre
aujourd'hui malgré ce que dit monsieur
guichard
qui n'est pas un orfèvre en la matière
les juridictions de proximité n'ont pas
tellement démérité que ça certes notre
rapporteur la guerre en commission le
bilan est mitigé mais il ya tout de même
un bilan tous les juges de proximité que
sont pas nulles c'est un juge de
proximité sont très bien les us de
proximité ont pu alléger la charge des
tribunaux d'instance qui va être
ailleurs accrue par le contentieux des
tutelles des majeurs et a cru aussi par
les gros regroupement des tribunaux du à
la carte judiciaire de votre funès
prédécesseur madame rachida dati alors
cette réforme qui est purement
utilitaire ne répond pas d'ailleurs aux
critiques qu'avait suscité à l'époque et
continue à susciter peut-être légitimité
c'est à dire statut précaire de ces
juges là dessus on ne fait rien
difficultés de recrutement on était rien
absence quelquefois ou insuffisance de
formation on ne fait rien et aujourd'hui
le dispositif s'était améliorée mais on
supprime la juridiction de proximité
alors pour en faire quoi
mais bien entendu on ne retient pas les
juges on les garde
qu'ils soient bons ou mauvais mais on
les met à la disposition du président du
tribunal de grande instance qui en fera
des bouche trous
si j'osais 1 un propos plus vulgaire je
dirais qu'un froid des bonniches
tribunal
voilà voilà la vraie raison et c'est
comme ça que ça se passera tout le monde
le sait c'est à dire que quand il
manquera un assesseur en correctionnelle
quand il vaincra nécessaire en
juridiction collégiale civile ou à titre
commercial lorsque ces tribunes ont la
compétence et bien on prendra un juste à
proximité et on le mettra la voilà
exactement le propos de ce texte
alors ensuite sous couvert de
simplification
le texte prévoit deux mesures qui sont à
l'entrepôt point de vue totalement
inacceptable
c'est tout d'abord la l'extension de
l'ordonnancé pénale
alors là parlons-en moi je pense et nous
pensons que le droit à l'audience c'est
à dire au contradictoire et la publicité
des débats est un droit absolu absolue
alors que je sais bien qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas à la mode et que la préférence
va d'autres solutions notamment on l'a
vu encore ce matin on l'a vu pour la
garde à vue
on le verra pour la loi sur les
utilisations d'office à la
visioconférence
alors là on a tout dit on a tout dit
évidemment les gens sont séparés par des
kilomètres
le jeu était un endroit la personne
gardée à vue ou mises en examen ou à
votre condamnation ou hospitalisés
d'office et ailleurs et là elle est
devant un écran et il paraît qu'il
faudrait qu'elle communique avec un juge
ou que le juge puisse communiquer avec
elle pour lui voler tout ceci vous en
conviendrez est totalement inacceptables
inacceptables et fait fi de ce qu'est
l'audience c'est à dire le dialogue
entre le juge et la personne qui est en
face d'elle quel que soit l'accueil soit
7,4 sonne et que parce par cette farce
est face à face le juge se fait une
opinion parce qu'il ya pas que ce qu'on
dit d'avoir un écran de télévision
il ya 60 ans le 10 et l'attitude qu'on a
il ya le le degré de francis qu'on met
dans ses réponses tout ceci est
perceptible dans l'audience il n'est pas
il ne sera pas par le système la visio
conférence
alors là vous les temps des ordonnances
pénales de façon absolument extensive
or on sait très bien tous les
parlementaires qui sont ici et qui ont
quelques années de ventes e ou derrière
eux plutôt de délai de demande à le
sable dans la permanence de recevons
beaucoup de gens qui ont eu dans de lens
pénale alors eh bien il ressemble ça ils
lisent mal acquis comprennent pas tout
ce qui est écrit
c'est le cas de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens malheureusement encore et
puis ne font rien qu'ils attendent
on le redit dans un petit bout pour
faire opposition il faut écrire il faut
écrire là pour faire une lettre alors
monsieur le député mais le visiteur est
ce que vous pouvez me faire la lettre ah
oui je veux bien mais je regarde jamais
les délais sont dépassés terminé on peut
plus faire la lettre j'avais fait des
lettres mais encore faut-il qu'ils
soient surpris à la vente dont vous
serez condamné voilà et vous ne pouvez
pas contester à mais si j'ai pas fait ça
comment la police m'arrêter non non
c'est fini vous êtes condamné c'est
terminé voilà donc voilà l'audience
pénale voient leur revente pénale voilà
l'extinction d'une audience pénale et je
m'étonne
monsieur le garde des sceaux vous qui
vous présenter comme un homme de terrain
très souvent que vous acceptez ceci car
vous connaissez très bien l'édifice
yable ont été lus d'un milieu rural mais
si vous êtes président du conseil
général d'un département qui est très
urbain mais il ya quand même des
communes rurales tout autour et vous
savez très bien que nos concitoyens
demandent de telles procédures ils n'y
comprennent strictement rien et qu'ils
sentent et qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils ont été condamnés comme ça par
l'arbitraire d'un juge qui rend un
machin et qui l'envoie alors plus grave
encore à mon avis plus grave encore est
l'extension du centre
plus grave encore à de nombreux points
de vue y compris d'un point de vue
constitutionnel
j'en fait de vous dire et l'extension du
champ de comparution comment ça
s'appelle ça sur reconnaissance
préalable de culpabilité
disons le plaider coupable pour parler
clair et ceci à l'ensemble des délits
bon alors évidemment on peut prévoir
quand sa rentrée en vigueur prophétie
rac terminé procès tapie terminé procès
est elle terminée plaidé coupable mais
bien sûr je suis coupable c'est ma foi
c'est ma très grande faute très bien on
négocie où les payer combien ou bien
taylor dan intel mairie ou tête par type
et combien pour vous est terminé y a
plus d'audience ya publicité c'est pas
la peine de faire rentrer les mises en
examen par une porte dérobée dans les
palais de justice c'est terminé voilà ce
que c'est que l'extension du billet
coupable et personne ici ne peut me
contredire s'il est de bonne foi
donc les procureurs alors les procureurs
certes monsieur le garde des sceaux vous
l'avait dit et redit au moment de la
garde à vue ce sont des magistrats
oui mais ce ne sont pas des juges mais
ce ne sont pas des juges
or or que font les procureurs
aujourd'hui les statistiques ce sont les
vôtres celle des chiffres clés de la
justice en 2010 sur disons gros
arrondissons un million cinq cent mille
affaires pénales poursuivables en 2009
huit cent cinquante quatre mille ans et
est entre guillemets juger par les
procureurs de la république chiffre
auquel il faudrait rajouter 188
classement sans suite
voilà en revanche mais pourvue devant le
juge d'instruction
le lieu des enfants le tribunal de
police en baisse de 18 7% 0 4% 4,1 pour
cent par rapport à l'année précédente et
se regardent et quand on verra les
chiffres de 2010 on s'apercevra que
c'est la même évolution donc le compte
le résultat c'est que les procureurs
deviennent des
juge s'était d'ailleurs qui connaissent
la plus grande la plus grande partie du
contentieux pénal
or ça à mon avis ça se heurte
aujourd'hui aux recommandations de la
cour européenne est compris de conseil
constitutionnel et je crois que ça sera
je pense que ça fera sanctionné
l'audience devient l'exception
le juge qui juge devient l'exception
c'est le procureur de la république qui
devient la règle
eh bien nous n'acceptons pas cette
dérive alors c'est vrai qu'il ya dans ce
texte
quelques dispositions qui sont plus
positives sur lesquelles je ne m'étends
pas c'est vrai que notre rapporteur yves
détraigne a fait un travail très
précautionneux et très minutieux et
qu'il a pu présenter des amendements qui
ont corrigé à certain nombre d'excès
d'ailleurs nous les avons approuvées
c'est vrai que le fait
contrairement peut-être à ma collègue
présidente du groupe communiste
je pense que la spécialisation de
certains tribunaux l'épaule
le fait est la propriété industrielle
viendra au tgs est peut-être plutôt
mieux parce qu'on trouvera des
magistrats spécialisés également
je me réjouis bien entendu avec quelques
années en arrière de la suppression du
tribunal aux armées de paris
mais je vois qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde est d'accord je me souviens des
débats en 1982 assemblée nationale de la
fureur l'assureur la fureur des cris et
des hurlements
on pourrait citer des parlementaires qui
sont décédés depuis d'ailleurs comme
jean foyer pour qu'ils avaient beaucoup
estiment mais qui n'en pouvaient plus
des rues que tu es contre cette attelle
qui était cet anneau armés bon alors
aujourd'hui on supprime le tribunal des
armées de paris
je m'en réjouis mais mme même si cette
suppression va différer l'examen des
hommes d'affaires qui était devant ce
tribunal et qui sont et dont le délai de
jugement sera encore allongée tard on
prévoit bien que le tgi de paris doit
pas cesser immédiatement ces affaires
alors j'en cite quelques unes
c'est quand même le rôle de l'armée face
au génocide rwandais c'est aussi les
bombardements de bouaké en 2004 en côte
d'ivoire où un certain nombre de
militaires français ont été tués
et où les tribunaux militaires d'un gma
voulu interroger les pilotes des avions
qui les avaient trucider c'est aussi
l'assassinât toujours en côte d'ivoire
du coupeur de route s'ils ont même
failli alors tout ceci va être encore
différé et peut-être un jour je ne sais
pas acté le prescription viendra
exonérer les militaires de délits qu'ils
auraient ou de crimes qu'il aurait
commis dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions ça existe également mes chers
collègues je le regrette donc vous
comprendrez que malgré ceci mais pour
toutes les raisons précédente
mon groupe votera contre ce texte merci
monsieur le sénateur la parole est à
monsieur nicolas alfonsi pour le groupe
rdse
c'est madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux chers collègues notre
discussion aujourd'hui ne peut être
séparée du contexte de crise aiguë qui
frappe notre j'y suis depuis maintenant
plusieurs années les retards en moyens
accumulés durant cette période sont
telles que les mesures de rattrapage de
l'ordre de 4% voté en loi de finances
sont loin de suffire à combler le manque
qui affecte notre système judiciaire
je rappellerai que le classement établi
en octobre dernier par la commission
européenne pour l'efficacité de la
justice place la france au 37e rang sur
43 pays en europe ce qui confirme
l'observation que je viens de faire
dès lors le présent projet de loi ne
répond pas à l'urgence avéré qu'il y à
mettre en l'air enfin une profonde
réforme de la justice
le mouvement de protestation des
personnels monsieur le ministre de la
justice du mois dernier n'est que la
dernière illustration en date de l'état
d'exaspération inquiétant qui accablent
notre monde judiciaire
la priorité aussi n'est certainement pas
d'examiner des textes comme celui ci en
procédure accélérée et pour parler
clairement ces textes est frappé de
l'incohérence incohérences d'abord les
dispositions hétérogène qui forment un
fourre tout dont un à peine à trouver la
ligne directrice
nous interrompons mois l'ont évoqué
pourquoi un texte haddock transposant
certaines recommandations du rapport
guinchard dont il y aurait beaucoup à
dire d'ailleurs par ailleurs alors qu'un
grand nombre de ses recommandations déjà
été mises en oeuvre dans d'autres textes
législatifs ou réglementaires
incohérences ensuite contre momentum
vous pouvez soumettre monsieur le
ministre un texte qui supprime les
juridictions de proximité mais vous
venez de présenter un projet de loi sur
les jurés populaires qui ajoute au
désordre les actifs actuels
le juge de proximité avait pourtant été
créée par votre majorité en 2002 en vain
il va beaucoup à dire là dessus
après des débats passionnés
afin de répondre je cite exponentielle
exposé des motifs de répondre aux
besoins d'une justice plus accessible
plus simple qu'à pas de mes rapports de
mieux appréhender les litiges de la vie
quotidienne
ce décès n'était pas en soi critiquable
mais au lieu de donner toutes leurs
chances à ces magistrats les moyens
budgétaires et humains n'ont jamais été
à la hauteur de l'ambition initiale en
raison je ne dirais pas de restriction
de crédit parce qu'il faut avoir
l'honnêteté de dire que depuis le début
depuis quelques années le budget de la
justice a régulièrement augmenté mais
les besoins étaient le retard accumulé
étaient telles par ailleurs qu'il faut
reconnaître encore une fois que les
besoins sont pas encore là les exemples
d'ailleurs montant le développement de
la situation actuelle tourne à l'absurde
on l'a rappelé jean roch notre collègue
michel qui l'a rappelé à orléans le
budget du tribunal d'instance a été
réduit de 30%
les juges de proximité ne peuvent donc
plus assister aux audiences
correctionnelles afin que des crédits
soient conservés pop et des vacataires
ces vacations des juges de proximité du
tribunal d'instance de tous ont été
divisées par deux en 2010 en raison
d'une baisse brutale des moyens de 27%
la cour d'appel de riom s'est même
trouvée dans l'impossibilité de
rémunérer des juges de proximité
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette science si
vous souhaitez la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur public sénat c'est
à 19 heures avec le journal présenté par
michel grossiord très bonne journée à
tous sur notre antenne